la emoción fue el común denominador de
las cintas que entraron en la
competencia del festival de cannes
cannes es como una segunda casa para los
hermanos belgas jean-pierre y luc
dardenne hace 20 años fundaron un cine
basado en lo real con el que hicieron
las magníficas rosetta y el niño que
ganaron la palma de oro en 2022 están en
la competencia con torii y lo quita
[Música]
y
mucho
y loquita es la historia de dos niños
inmigrantes ilegales que vienen de venir
en busca de los preciados papeles para
quedarse en europa
los dardenne abordan aquí la condición
de los menores solos seres humanos
vulnerables y abusados de múltiples
maneras
[Música]
todos los
juristas del tiempo
el director italiano mario martone está
en la competencia de cannes con
nostalgia una reflexión sobre la
nostalgia de la juventud del país natal
y de la familia
[Música]
tras 40 años en el extranjero feliz se
regresa a su barrio napolitano vuelve
para ver a su madre pero le embargan los
recuerdos y la añoranza del lugar su
presencia termina siendo un estorbo para
un capo local de la camorra quien fue su
amigo de juventud
[Música]
no está allí a cuenta con la actuación
del magnético pierfrancesco favino
estremecedora en el papel de este hombre
que cree que el tiempo lo cura todo